[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
photo avec Claude bonjour bonjour ça va
bien on va parler évidemment de votre
travail tout à l'heure voilà l'Aubrac
notamment soulage aussi
et mais vous avez
convié aussi un autre photographe
bonjour Jacques Martin bonjour alors si
on se précipite c'est jusqu'à vendredi
on peut vous voir voir vos photos prises
bail en cours tout à fait tout à fait je
décroche vendredi après-midi
notamment et donc on a l'occasion de
voir vos photos peut-être que vous
pouvez nous présenter Claude Jacquie
Martin ah ben bien sûr Jacquie Martin on
se connaît depuis 1980 quelque chose
comme ça
Jacky Martin à cette époque-là était
président du Photo Club d'Élancourt
moi-même j'étais président du Photo Club
de Voisins-le-Bretonneux qui savent
l'époque s'appelait fait partager son
donc avec Jacky Martin on a on a
collaboré mais on a fait surtout une
grande collaboration nous avons fait
réaliser donc sur la ville nouvelle 51 à
Yvelines la première gainage d'art
photographique de 51 en Yvelines donc
Jacky a été à l'organisation on a
travaillé tous les deux maintenant la
main je suis hier et cette exposition
avait eu un réel succès puisque nous
avions comme l'invité d'honneur je Willy
Ronis avec ses photos couleurs nous
avions Gérard vandilstadt que
connaissait Jacky donc qui l'a fait
venir et aussi un yvelinois Robert le
batteur parce que je pense que Robert
avait fait une très belle exposition
dans un musée qui était patrimon d'ici
donc voilà donc
comment la photo est venue est entrée
dans votre vie oh je suis tombé dedans
tout petit
je me souviens j'habitais à
Neauphle-le-Château et j'avais monté un
labo photo dans vous avez
il était de quand il habitait dans la
maison dans une maison qui était en bas
de à la limite de pontcharpin et enfin
je n'ai pas connu mais je l'ai pas
photographié malheureusement donc
j'avais
monté un labo photo et puis je j'ai
continué
pendant toute ma toute toute ma carrière
en parallèle à ma carrière photo
professionnelle qui était que j'étais
ingénieur dans l'informatique et j'ai
fait énormément de photographies
vous avez aussi fort fait de la
formation alors j'en fais toujours j'en
fais toujours où elle est retraite à 64
ans c'est pas pour moi
et j'ai je continue à faire de la
formation là dans 15 jours je serai à
Montauban et à Albi aller faire de la
formation sur la lecture
le lecteur d'image donc je continue un
peu moins la prise de vue et pour
beaucoup de formations voilà et
qu'est-ce qu'il y a changé au fond
depuis le moment vous avez commencé la
photographie et c'est vrai que les
techniques ont extrêmement enfin évolué
beaucoup évoluer
est-ce que le fond le métier enfin l'art
de la photographie a beaucoup changé et
bien moi j'ai commencé dans
en Argentine les mains dans le
révélateur ce qui en ont parlé tout à
l'heure avec Claude c'est quand même la
base lorsqu'on a fait de l'argentique on
comprend mieux le numérique parce que
toute la démarche ah oui c'est mieux
d'en avoir fait parce que toute la
démarche qu'on a avec Photoshop ou
Lightroom
vient de la méthodologie qu'on avait en
argentique donc on comprend mieux ce
qu'on fait avec les masques les travail
par zone
on comprend mieux
toute l'approche de la correction d'une
image sous Photoshop lorsqu'on a fait
avant de
l'argentique mais c'est vrai que
l'argentique
contrairement à votre invité
récent
Jean-Pierre Evrard qui travaille qui ne
travaille pas
on a une facilité d'approche qui est qui
est quand même confortable mais
que vous utilisez beaucoup les
techniques modernes mais ce qui est pas
une sorte de je pose la question à tous
les deux vertiges de vos justement les
évolutions de la technologie
qu'est-ce qui même de questionnement de
de ce que va devenir qu'est-ce que ça va
être la photo dans les années qui
viennent est-ce que c'est vous poser ces
questions et ce que vous avez des
réponses
ce que je voudrais dire quand même pour
continuer le portrait de mon ami Jacky
c'est que il a été pendant presque 10
ans je crois président de la Fédération
Photographique de France au cours de
laquelle il l'a fait vraiment évoluer
donc il a fait passer d'un CAP je dirais
très traditionnel un cap plus moderne et
donc Jacky là il a marqué son passage à
la Fédération Photographique de France
donc voilà je voulais rajouter
internationale internationale et bon on
a arrêté bon il y a un peu plus d'une
dizaine d'années
qui était un magazine papier à séux et
qui était un petit peu compliqué ça
coûte cher et là actuellement je
collabore
un autre magazine qui s'appelle
openaille le ouvert point fr qui est un
magazine uniquement sur internet qui est
gratuit donc n'importe qui peut
s'abonner et on a hier soir on a fêté
nos
six ans et le numéro 31 est sorti ce
matin c'est tout à fait tout à fait
tout le monde peut aller voir et
s'abonner pour recevoir tous les deux
mois un lien sur les nouveaux numéros et
là on est très axé sur une certaine
photographie
contemporaine sans renier sans renier la
plus traditionnelle donc je reviens ma
question donc oui vous imaginez ce que
va devenir la photo vous parler de
l'intelligence artificielle un peu or
tout à l'heure
est-ce que ça va changer
par cette technologie qui va très vite
quoi on ne sait pas tout le travail
qu'on faisait sous Photoshop moi j'ai
fait beaucoup de photos de photomontages
je sais pas si on les verra tout à
l'heure bah voilà demain
dogs de Human dolphe
et alors Alfred c'est Alfred Hitchcock
parce que là il y a on retrouve un peu
les oiseaux avec un corbeau une mouette
San Francisco le pont de San Francisco
Vertigo
donc là c'est il y a un peu cette
évidemment dans dans ce ce ce chien qui
est à Saint-Bernard quoi c'est ça un peu
le latitude
aux hommes alors quand je disais voilà
vous utilisez des là c'est du Photoshop
alors là c'est du Photoshop là sur une
image comme ça il y a beaucoup de
travail arrivé à faire les détourage les
prises de vue adaptées et puis
le problème c'est qu'une image comme ça
maintenant en intelligence artificielle
il suffit de décrire l'image que l'on
veut on dit un studio intitulé de
d'Alfred Hitchcock
[Musique]
un Saint-Bernard et je pense que
est capable de produire une image proche
de celle-ci alors sans sans
artificielle
voilà c'est ça c'est ça la grosse
difficulté de l'avenir on s'est vraiment
alors on peut regarder d'autres images
de ces human dogs voilà là ça c'est le
cowboy chez le cow-boy alors bon ça
c'est aussi une fait dans un endroit où
ça reconstitué ou est-ce que vous
récupérer le four alors là oui c'est un
chien que j'ai photographié
opéré en Yvelines le décor c'est
monument de vallée aux États-Unis et le
cowboy je l'ai pris à Cody dans le
Royaume-Uni donc voilà c'est un montage
c'est un montage
de plusieurs photos que plusieurs prises
de vue que c'est voilà donc
c'est génial alors il faut je rajouterai
parce que je vais laisser Jacky et
expliquer c'est que le montage photo
existe depuis des années il suffit
parfois d'aller en Arles quand on
regarde les les photos qui ont été
prises en URSS sur la Place Rouge ou
envoyer des gens arriver disparaître
comme ça donc ça existait socialiste
on continue alors celle-ci a été faite
dans la passerelle ici à
saint-quentin-en-y
le personnage c'est un portrait de mon
épouse et j'ai rajouté une j'ai rajouté
à bouledogue
donc bon
elle était ravie oui pas tout à fait pas
tout à fait mais bon disons que c'est
c'était assez
intéressant ils ont de faire ça dans
dans la mise en scène c'est vrai que la
difficulté c'est d'avoir l'idée et de
savoir comment on va composer l'image
parce que il y a plusieurs éléments il y
a le décor il y a le personnage
l'attitude il y a la lumière et tout ça
doit être doit être travaillé pour que
faire quelque chose de cohérent
absolument oui il faut que ça a l'air
naturel même si on sait très bien que
c'est pas naturel absolument mais il
faut que comme on disait tout à l'heure
sur Hitchcock quoi c'est vrai que voilà
on peut on peut aller voir dans les
détails et trouver des choses alors
euh ça c'est donc cette série de Human
dogs ça va oui voilà ça c'est le
policeman alors un policeman à Hanoï
devant le mausolée au chimie
alors en réalité le polishman je l'ai
pris derrière dans le petit jardin que
l'on voit au fond
et puis je les ramené
je l'ai ramené devant la tête de chien
c'est un chien que j'avais photographié
en Chine et donc là j'ai fait ce ce
petit pages et la cohérence dans
l'attitude dans la lumière dans voilà
c'est c'est des pardon ça c'est un
autoportrait pendant une manif boulevard
Voltaire
bien que je l'ai fait il y a longtemps
mais
d'actualité et le chien j'avais pris la
tête de chien en Argentine et
donc voilà c'est des c'est sorti de
photos que vous avez fait nous-mêmes
c'est des photos qui mesurent combien
disons que bon je
l'exposition les photos sont de format
A3 à AA1 ça fait déjà c'est déjà assez
grand donc j'en ai beaucoup en a deux
celle-ci par exemple dans les dans
l'exposition est en format A1
c'est-à-dire c'est un 680 si je me
souviens
de photos alors ça c'est donc cette
série human dogs il y a aussi une série
sur les cartes postales c'est pas sur
les cartes postales alors ça c'est
lorsque je fais une exposition j'ai des
cartes postales à disposition là il y a
tout il y a presque toute ma série alors
il y a dedans alors si on va zoomer il y
a vous êtes très fasciné par les
États-Unis alors bon oui c'est mon
principal sujet alors j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur la Route 66 que j'ai
parcouru cinq fois la Route 66 les
grands parcs depuis 40 ans j'y vais
presque tous les ans
donc je connais cette région là et dans
ma vie antérieure comme comme ingénieur
j'allais très fréquemment à Phoenix et
Phoenix est au cœur de tous ces paysages
donc j'avais l'occasion de d'aller
visiter
le Grand Canyon monument de vallée Brest
canyon
c'est une région tout à fait
extraordinaire c'est-à-dire vous faites
quelques kilomètres et vous avez des
paysages totalement différents
200 300 km et vous passez du Grand
Canyon à monument de vallée et ça n'a
rien à voir au niveau paysage et puis
c'est monumental aussi et c'est
monumental
la lumière moi j'y suis allé plusieurs
fois dans chaque dans chaque parc
la lumière est différentes alors la
lumière pour un photographe c'est
l'essentiel donc le plus difficile après
c'est de choisir le résultat lorsqu'on a
moi j'ai pris des milliers de photos
dans ces coins là et le livre il y a 100
photos et
dans le Canada
dans l'EHPAD
c'était un photographe du siècle dernier
qui
n'est jamais sorti des États-Unis sauf
en dans les années 70 il avait été
invité par les Rencontres d'Arles et il
a eu sa première exposition en dehors de
en dehors des États-Unis et c'est là où
j'ai découvert tous ces grands parcs
dans le travail de de ce photographe il
est mort dans les années 80 et c'est à
cette époque là que j'ai fait mes
premiers voyages aux États-Unis
c'est-à-dire il y a eu une quarantaine
d'années
toutes mes photos sont un hommage
et que j'ai appelé dans les pas
d'ancelada j'ai été partout il avait
photographié mais j'ai été un petit peu
plus loin parce que j'ai fait beaucoup
plus
son travail d'une certaine façon
pas tout à fait j'ai pas j'ai pas tout à
fait le même niveau il travaillait à la
Chambre
13-18 20 25 la chambre grand format mais
c'est tout à fait étonnant parce que il
y a un siècle il y a dans 50 60 ans
c'était pas évident de voyager
dans ces régions là les accès dans les
parcs étaient beaucoup plus compliqués
le matériel était beaucoup plus lourd
beaucoup plus compliqué à mettre en
place donc
c'était tout à fait intéressant la
matière dans la manière dont il a visité
tous ces parcs et il a inventé quelque
chose qui était important en argentique
le zones système c'est un système de
d'exposition à la prise de vue et de
manière de développer les plans films et
c'était quelque chose qui a été très
très utilisé il y a quelques dizaines
d'années j'ai d'ailleurs un ami
Pierre-Yves Mahé directeur de l'école
speos des clubs de photos à Paris qui a
écrit un excellent bouquin sur la zone
système où il explique en beaucoup de
pages comment ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne mais ça c'est pour les
photographes c'est pour les photographes
c'est à dire en deux mots on expose sur
les basses lumières et on développe sur
les hautes lumières voilà j'ai tout dit
non mais c'est intéressant ce que il dit
dans son dans son l'explication qu'il en
a qui en fait parce que même aujourd'hui
à partir du numérique je vais dire on
peut appliquer pratiquement les mêmes
règles pour possibilité d'avoir des des
grandes masses si tu veux qui sont
comment dire où il y a pas de détails
quoi et l'exemple qui disait tu
photographies un tas de charbon chez moi
mais tu vois bien les boulets voilà
c'est ça voilà c'est l'exemple qui donne
qui alors moi ce que je rajoute ce que
vient de dire Jacky c'est que
photographie c'est écrire avec la
lumière donc si on parle de l'étymologie
du mot photos lumière
je laisse Jacky comme tu veux j'ai déjà
beaucoup parlé
parce que sinon on a plus beaucoup de
temps ce que tu présentes là les photos
de de des événements dans le ciel c'est
quand même aussi c'est un sacré travail
de de la part de Jackie en terme de de
d'amélioration de l'image qu'on voit
parce que faire quand tu as des hautes
lumières comme le Soleil ou la Lune
c'est pas très évident si tu veux de
faire des fautes bien la route donc il y
a beaucoup de photos j'ai des amis en
Norvège et j'y vais assez souvent
faut dire que je suis un grand voyageur
j'ai fait beaucoup j'ai fait beaucoup de
pays et la Norvège bon bah c'est riche
au niveau des aurores boréales il y a la
Voie Lactée aussi qu'on voit pas très
très bien c'est
un monument de vallée il y a la grande
éclipse de
et là au mois d'octobre j'y retourne
parce que une éclipse au mois d'octobre
donc qui est une éclipseulaire c'est un
peu moins intéressant vous retournez où
Ben dans l'ouest américain
ou pas cette éclipse et puis bon il y a
une éclipse de lune que j'ai
photographiée dans mon jardin donc voilà
c'est et la photo que tu as juste au
dessus de ton texte Sky event c'est
en allant vers Moab dans l'Utah c'est un
lever de lune sur
sur une sur une arche qui est le subord
de la au bord de la route lever d'une
avec deux personnages qui sont qui
étaient grimper jusque à la base de
l'Arche et qui se trouve devant la lune
là c'est pareil c'est un petit peu le
cadeau qu'on peut avoir parfois
avec le vert alors ça c'est une aurore
boréale
dans les îles Lofoten en Norvège c'est
magnifique c'est vrai que c'est c'est
presque de la récréation d'un point
d'impression alors que c'est la nature
là c'est la nature
c'est au niveau du cercle arctique et on
a
des nuits qui sont très riches avec les
aurores boréales il y a d'autres nuits
où il se passe rien c'est un petit peu
la chance aussi alors Claude il faut
qu'on parle parce qu'il nous reste plus
je voudrais
quand même parler du travail de Jacky
parce que je l'ai invité aussi pour ça
parce que le travail photographique
qu'il a fait la présentation de son
exposition au prisme il faut vraiment
aller voir ces images il a il a pris il
a pris le temps de développer sur des
papiers japonais etc c'est vraiment une
exposition qu'il faut voir parce que
elle est digne des plus grands
photographes au mois de septembre à
Rambouillet
photos
très sympathique il y a une belle
programmation il y a un restaurant il y
a du piano jazz c'est vraiment très
sympa alors Claude on a on a enfin on a
quelques minutes encore pour parler un
petit peu de de votre travail
apporter quelques photos alors celle-là
alors ça c'est une photo que j'ai fait à
comment s'appelle dans l'Aubrac c'est le
braque le jour de la transition
c'est les Steve c'est le départ des
troupes
c'est un événement qui se situe sur la
fin du mois de mai quand les
propriétaires de troupeau de montent les
bêtes
et puis se nourrir tout l'été donc voilà
ça c'est
le personnage est prêt on va voir des
paysages oui c'est magnifique évidemment
moi ça c'est une photo j'ai faite le
soir au coucher du soleil après le
coucher du soleil lorsque le ce qu'on
appelle leur bleu arrive si tu veux sur
sur les paysages leur bleue pour la
situer c'est à peu près une heure après
le coucher du soleil
du silence de l'espace
on ressent évidemment ça moi je suis
impressionné par ce par ces paysages qui
sont immenses ou quelque part tu te
retrouves avec toi-même face à
l'immensité de cette nature et j'ai
organisé plusieurs fois des le des
reportages sur la transhumance montrer
les troupeaux c'est bien mais ce qui
était intéressant c'est surtout montrer
tout ce qui se passe sur tout ce qui se
passe autour donc
ça c'est de l'Aubrac alors c'est en noir
et blanc oui pourquoi le noir et blanc
de temps en temps je trouve que
c'est serait pour moi une facilité de
manière à avoir une série cohérente
parce que comme des photos on va en
prendre sur plusieurs plusieurs mois un
peu le pusion de voyage après pour
retrouver des bonnes couleurs
colorimétrique c'est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus intéressant alors après ça
c'est donc toujours le
je crois qu'il y en a une loutre de
photos sur Versailles oui
alors ça c'est plutôt c'est des
promenades non c'est pas que des
promenades non c'est plus que ça c'est
plus que ça parce que bon d'une part
j'habite Versailles ça met très facile
les dents dans le parc du château mais
c'est aussi pour ressentir ce que ce
personnage qui était Louis XIV a fait
donc quand il est devenu roi bien sûr en
1648 et 43 pardon à l'amour de son père
si tu veux donc
de voir ce qu'il a fait le parce que il
faut il fallait quand même comprendre
que la France était fracturée suite au
de guerre de religion et que lui il a
essayé de construire ce pays de le de
faire
voilà c'est ça et donc j'ai fait
plusieurs sujets dont un sur la manière
de montrer les jardins de Versailles par
Louis XIV parce que il a écrit 6 guide
pour faire visiter les jardins de Louis
XIV à ses amis et on peut retrouver ces
livres
[Musique]
de notre noix alors moi les photos que
j'ai vu j'ai pas vu toutes les photos
mais on voit aussi beaucoup les les
visiteurs oui c'est ça que c'est ça qui
nous intéresser alors pour dire que moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de montrer ce
que fait l'homme donc l'homme dans son
environnement de pouvoir les observer
c'est
pour montrer ce que l'attitude de ces
gens devant les tableaux de soulage où
tout le monde cherche à comprendre ce
que soulage a fait ça le soulage il a
fait ses tableaux à partir de de la
couleur qui recouvrait de noir et après
avec une spatule il commence à peine il
faisait il donnait des des stries dans
ces tableaux pour faire ressortir la
couleur qu'il y avait au départ montrer
que le noir était de lumière aussi voilà
et puis pour quand même parler de la
lumière il faut se rappeler que soulage
c'est lui qui a refait les vitraux de
l'abbaye de Conques absolument donc
justement où il a voulu refaire rentrer
la lumière dans l'abbaye de Conques et
on rappelle qu'il est
[Musique]
donc ça sera exposé là-bas pendant ce
festival merci beaucoup Jacques libertin
merci beaucoup Claude merci de reparler
de reparler de soulage parce que ça va
être c'est intéressant quand même mes
photos sont prêtes les photos sont
accrochées
mais bon il faut que je discute
maintenant dans quelles conditions et je
vais avoir une exposition aussi sur le
marché de l'essac d'accord
vous reviendrez régulièrement à nous
parler de photos mais ça serait bien que
comme je te disais on va faire ça on va
faire quelque chose merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci de ton
accueil
[Musique]